with VI currency they just print
unquantifiable amounts of money they
just print it into worthlessness in
order for something to actually have
worth there needs to be scarcity there's
no scarcity to the US dollar if you can
just print it with Bitcoin there's only
ever going to be 21 million points no
more can ever be created and that is so
important even gold doesn't even have a
hard cap there's always more that can be
mined from the ground I think there's an
asteroid in space which can make
everyone on earth a millionaire and so
there's always going to be more never
before in history have we truly seen
money which is absolutely
non-confiscatable